I keep getting an email from true rife saying I should update my rife machine. Is this necessary?
So the update that rife had, well, it is expired now. So that was only in the month of February.
They had an update if you had an F117. So if you had an F117 machine, which if you started with us after 2020 ish, we were the first first clinic ever to get the F122.
So everybody has the F122 that started after that. But if you started with us prior to that, you still may have an F117 machine.
Is it a good idea to upgrade that to an F1122, which is the latest model?
Well, sure. That's always great to have the latest model. Is it a stronger, more powerful machine? No, not really. Is it going to help you more?
No, not really. Is it going to do a better job at getting you getting better? No, not really. Why would I want to upgrade the only reason to upgrade would be to you have the latest equipment.
And it's going to be more serviceable down the road. That would be the only reason why you would really want to upgrade. It's like, okay, well, then I'll know I'll have the best, the latest and greatest piece of equipment that, you know, there may be a time where they're not going to service the F117.
We've had patients that started with us 15 years ago that are still doing great that we've gotten calls from in the last several weeks, say that they sent their F117 in for repair.
And true life said, well, you really need to upgrade it to F122. So they ended up upgraded to F122. Now could they have gotten repaired if they would have pushed for it? I don't know.
True life is going through change and ownership. And so far they've been great to work with, but, you know, I don't know if they're trying to just push people to the F122 for sake of ease more easily repair.
And heartier, sturdier machine with good to say these people had it for 12, 15 years and their F117 was working great.
So if you have an F117, you may want to call to life and ask them about upgrading to the F122 or you could call us and we could help you with that too.